[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank in job or
is I prefer to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John answer your questions
give you dubious advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon how are you doing John I'm
great
everything is wonderful it is a
beautiful day here in Indianapolis it's
been unseasonable warm life is good how
are you I'm good it is snowing a lot
here so not uncie's really warm yes it's
coming coming down but but III like the
part where you're doing great which is
unusual has not been the case are you
just putting on a happy face for us nope
I mean I'm a little bit stressed out but
because I got I'm doing some stuff but
work stuff but no life is good can I
read you a short poem yeah okay it's by
Emily Dickinson
I really think you're gonna like this
poem Hank I've okay I'll try to listen I
have organized it for you okay this is a
Hank green Emily Dickinson poem of which
there are not many it must be noted it's
its poem - OH - that's how it's usually
known faith is a fine invention for
gentlemen who see but microscopes are
prudent in an emergency I liked it and I
thought you might I thought you might
want to Emily Dickinson shortest poems
but also in my opinion one of my
favorites yeah it feels it feels like
one of those one-liners from that guy
who wrote one-liners sure it's also you
know an interesting thing about this
poem is that it's it's sort of like
translated differently oh yeah
like sometimes it's it's it's written as
faith is a fine invention for gentlemen
who see and then other times it's
written as faith is a fine engine faith
is a fine invention when gentlemen can
see huh well how is it in it for first I
have to say I'm talk about the guy who
wrote the candy is dandy but liquor is
quicker one it felt like one of those
Ogden Nash yeah but a second how is
Emily Dickinson's work translated when
she wrote in English the answer is
that I don't know but the probable
answer is that because Emily Dickinson's
poems were written in drafts and many
were never published or they were only
or when they were published they were
published in highly edited form it's
probable that one of those is the highly
edited non ideal non Emily Dickinson
herself form yeah she had she had her
editor who was like I don't really
understand why people like this person
but I guess we'll keep publishing them
and we'll J well but we'll make it more
appropriate we'll make it better right
there's the most insulting thing of all
time
yeah right like we're gonna improve on
Emily Dickinson's like her language
choices oh man oh man the editors are
great though my editor makes my books
better but I am NOT Emily Dickinson no
you are not
hey John yes want to answer some
questions do I
I felt like we got to the questions
really fast this time well it was an
exceptionally short poem yes this this
podcast is coming out on Monday next
Monday well the project for awesome
you'll still be going on then you can
still get perks yes the eight hour
livestream will probably have just ended
but if you go to your web browser and
you search project for awesome 2015 you
can still get perks that's why I'm
stressed out by the way is because I'm
working on my project for awesome video
but yeah so you can go to go to your
browser search for project for awesome
2015 and you can go to the IndieGoGo and
there are amazing amazing perks
including an exclusive episode of dear
Hank and John that will be released no
other way and that's right I understand
that most people will be listening to
this not on Monday and I apologize to
them but for those of you who really
keep up and listen right when it comes
out that's for you check out that
exclusive episode of dear Hank and John
you can also get things like Hank and
Kathryn watching Star Wars together and
then you can kind of play along by
listening along or Sarah and I watching
the movie Paper Towns together which we
did a couple nights ago Hank and we had
it like a bottle of wine when we saw
the commentary and did not have a bottle
of wine when we finished the commentary
and you can really follow along as
things devolve oh but there are lots of
other perks from socks to hats you
forgot about your poetry podcast oh yeah
and there's a there's there's also a
digital perk where you can get me
reading you some poems in fact I read
you the poem that I just read you but
the other version of it oh and also also
I read lots of longer poems but there
are lots of they're amazing perks you
can get socks you can get a hat you can
get nerdfighter art it's just it's a you
can get me calling you on Christmas Day
oh wow I didn't know about that that's
cool so anyway there's lots of great
perks check it out a project for awesome
calm and all the money goes to benefit
charities chosen by the nerdfighter
community or else Save the Children and
the UNHCR which are great organizations
so yeah now let's answer some questions
but definitely check out the project for
awesome unless it's already over in
which case I'm sorry there's a little
beat there'll be one next year this
question is from Monika who asks dear
Hank and John I'm curious as to why you
are able to find so many examples of
farm animals horses pigs chickens goats
etc going feral and living in the wild
why is that not the case for wild cows
are they more valuable to humans than
horses and so we've kept better tabs on
them or are they just dumber understand
I'm talking about your garden-variety
bovines not bison or Longhorn but honest
to goodness cows Wow
well John I have news on this front
there are feral cows no way it happens
yeah yeah it happens and and it has
happened throughout the history of
humans relationship with cows they get
out and then if if they can the thing
that needs to happen is that the females
need to meet up with a male yeah because
otherwise you can just get that you can
get the cows or the steers steers being
neutered males to just you can just like
rope them up or herd them into a herd
and be like you're my cows now Thanks
now I have much more money so
but what happens if they meet up with a
bull is that suddenly the herd becomes
dangerous and you have to you can't just
walk up to it and be like you're my cows
now that they will the Bulls will
protect the cows from you but the reason
why this isn't a real problem is because
one cows are valuable and so people will
just take the wild ones too they are
destructive and so the government will
help people take the wild ones and three
they do not do what other feral animals
do which is run away cow herds just
stand there they stand their ground and
they're like you want to mess come mess
and then they shoot the bull and then
they take the cast so it's a pretty easy
feral infestation quote-unquote to take
care of and that is why there are not
herds of feral cows running all across
America because they cause a lot of
destruction they cause economic problems
and and they're pretty easy to wrangle
up unlike feral pigs for example which
are really good at hiding and running
away and finding other things to do with
their you know they can and also are
good at living in places where they're
it's sort of difficult to access like
swamps and stuff speaking of which I
actually came across a feral pig
recently here in Indiana oh yeah well I
was hiking and it was terrifying it was
only in the distance but I mean it was
it could have easily killed me I have a
very low tolerance when I am out for a
walk for mammal sightings I got out
particularly like seeing human mammals
but I particularly dislike seeing
non-human mammals that weigh more than
about 12 pounds yes mmhmm yeah okay and
this cow like a coyote will put the fear
of God into me even though I
I know rationally that I could fight off
a coyote if I needed to but this this
this pig I could not have fought it off
yeah I came across a group of feral pigs
and in Florida once and they were maybe
10 feet away from me when I like when I
spooked them and they ran away which is
really good because sometimes they run
toward especially if there
if they're bores and they're yeah they
are you're dangerous animals and do you
know what a group of pigs is called Hank
no I do not a drift oh wow that's nice a
drift of pigs yeah I like the word drift
it's a good one all right let's move on
to the next question this comes from cam
who writes dear John and Hank as cold
and flu season has been on the rise I've
noticed something strange generally
after people sneeze we express empathy
by saying things like bless you or
gesundheit but what do we do when people
cough cam then goes on to explain which
is very true that at least in the United
States when people cough they themselves
often say excuse me as if they have done
something wrong there is something they
need to apologize for
whereas when people sneeze they never
say excuse me or rarely yeah because
everyone around them is so busy blessing
them well first I'll say I want to ask
you John is it an expression of empathy
when we say bless you after someone
sneezes I don't feel like it isn't a
great question I don't feel like it is
an expression of empathy I feel like
it's an extinct it's a it's an
expression of cultural norm but it's but
it's not like I don't feel bad for the
person who just sneezed I quite like
sneezing as it made unless it's like
I've in the middle of a fit or something
but like one or two sneezes I'm like
yeah that was good I yeah I said I don't
think it's empathetic historically it is
not about empathy
it's about sympathy because when people
were sneezing they were believed with
some good reason to be dying and
therefore you would say you know God
bless you here in your final days on
earth also get away from me
exactly yeah yeah I or something like
that I would actually be really
interested to know that the deep origins
of bless you I feel a little bit like
it's just something to say which is why
I quite like gesundheit which is more
like to your health or something right
also an acknowledgement of sympathy but
I concern yeah I mean I'm concerned that
we don't say something about the cough
because the coffee's just as alarming as
the sneeze I think we even either need
like put the coffin the sneezy same
category where you either say excuse me
my bad I am very sorry for having
coughed and/or sneezed in this public
situation or or there's a universal
bless you / gesundheit that covers
coughing that encompasses coughing I'm
gonna argue that we need to expand bless
you to include coughing yeah I I agree
with you
in fact I do that or I have heard people
do that and I also say excuse me when I
sneeze and I like not all the time but
if it feels appropriate if it feels like
I've interrupted someone or a triplet
place and/or there's like a perform
performance going on and I've sneezed
yeah so I think that I think it can be
both and I and I live in a place where
they say bless you when you cough as
well fascinating we are just we are just
too too polite okay we have another
question this one it's just this is a
great question on so many levels it's
from Kaitlyn she writes dear John and
Hank I recently got into the competitive
Pokemon scene by the way if you want to
know how to get your question on dear
Hank and John you should begin with I
recently got into the competitive
Pokemon Z I'm gonna love any question
that comes after that I find that when I
practice online at home I play fairly
well but in the live tournament setting
my nerves get the best of me and make me
play badly do you have any dubious
advice for me I do oh yeah mine is
practice just keep doing it and and and
and that's that's the trick
but John might have some better advice
well I think in general that confidence
is very weird like the way that
confidence functions inside of people
fascinates me because when you have
confidence it seems obvious that it
matters and that it's worth having and
it seems obvious how you get it right
you get it by having it but when you
don't have confidence it's incredibly
difficult to figure out how to acquire
it because it's both having confidence
and not having confidence our feedback
loops that can sort of spiral in into
themselves so in my experience that we
the I agree with Hank that practice is
important but I also think like right
before you go on or go out into the
competitive pokemon hallway where you
play a competitive pokemon or wherever
it is hotel basement I'm imagining tell
yourself tell yourself like whisper it
to yourself so that you can hear
yourself say it I am a very good
competitive pokemon player I I am going
to do well I am gonna char zard this
mofo right just repeat those words over
and over and over again this also works
when it's not competitive pokemon by the
way right before I go on stage for any
event I close my eyes and I just whisper
to myself it's time to Charizard this
moment alright this question is from
Phoebe who asks dear Hank and John this
is not a question for asking advice I
was just wondering what both of you are
looking at while recording the podcast
do you video chat what are you seeing
while discussing human existence what
are you seeing John I'm seeing my
computer screen so rosianna are my
wonderful production partner and also
invaluable contributor - dear Hank and
John
rosianna halse rojas sends us an email
every week with lots and lots of
questions and so I'm looking at that
email and also I'm looking on my
computer screen at the short poem that I
just read what are you looking at well I
think that as as I make the podcast I
look at different things but most of my
eyes just wander and I sort of my visual
sense is kind of cut off and I just
listen to you and I think about what I'm
going to say and I do not see a lot but
when I am seeing I'm either looking at
the the audio track to make sure that
it's recording correctly and I'm looking
out the windows at the snow falling down
in random patterns that sounds yeah or I
might look at some of the art on my
walls
when I say art I mean you know Star Trek
posters and yeah sometime
grab this tube of travel sized
toothpaste and I squeeze it I don't know
why but that's the thing that I do
during dear Hank and John I think all of
our lives are richer for knowing that
Hank our next question comes from Kate
who asks dear John and Hank I just moved
from the u.s. to Rwanda to work in
international development I'm in my 20s
and single and the expat community here
is a lot of families what advice do you
have for someone without kids to make
social connections with families thanks
Kate oh my gosh I said that because
there's lots of exclamation points again
that's why I said thanks I don't know
III am a I am not single but I don't
have kids and all my friends do and I
just I just like them you know you just
like scoop them up and you're like hey
kiddo
what's up tell me about your trucks and
that's that and yeah and that's all they
need just yeah kids are great they they
have a very they have a very interesting
way of looking at the world and I enjoy
it and I I like it to inform the way I
look at the world it's not all about
what's gonna happen and what has
happened it's mostly about what's
happening right that's a great point
about kids one of the things I really
admire about Hank is the way that he
talks to children in precisely the way
same way that he talks to adults
so like when Hank is talking to my
children if they say if like if Henry is
like Darth Sidious is the worst is the
worst in Star Wars Hank will be like
well that's not fair at all and Hank
will be like don't you think that Darth
Sidious is partly a result of his of his
circumstances Henry have you really
thought this through is there such a
thing as good guys and bad guys or are
ultimately we all somewhere in the
middle and just coming into conflict
yeah and Henry is like check out this
truck Henry Henry recently did something
that was that was untoward while I was
was watching him and I was I was
disappointed in him that he did that
thing and I said I said well he had done
something mean to Alice and then he
laughs
and I said to Henry what about that do
you think was funny and What did he say
he he looked very kind of sad he'll all
right he looked like he had been
chastised but I was I was legitimately
interested in what what he thought was
funny about that right you weren't I
guess you were just curious yeah I
wanted to know well I think but I think
that gets to the answer which is that
being curious like around kids is great
and so that would be my first piece of
advice my second piece of advice would
be like when it comes to adults who have
kids I know it feels like particularly
because you're probably significantly
younger than most of them that they are
fundamentally different from you that
like they have something figured out
that you don't or that they're in like a
fundamentally different part of life
than you are but I think over time
you'll find that that's not really
totally true that we're all sort of like
on this weird continuum and it doesn't
have like you know one point as the
start and another point as the finish
it's more like like random circles where
you come backwards and go forwards and
go up and down and in through multiple
dimensions and so if you think of it
just as like they're further along on
the continuum then then you are then
you'll never quite feel comfortable with
them but I don't think that's really I
don't think that's really how it works
yeah it's interesting that as I've
gotten older I've realized that those
moments in conversations where you don't
have anything to contribute are not
because you don't know as much as
someone they're not because you're not
as old or in the same place as someone
it's just something that happens right
you know you're gonna be at a party and
suddenly they're gonna start talking
about talking about like ultramarathon
skiing and you're gonna be like well I
don't have anything to add to this
particular part of the conversation so I
will just stand here and learn about
ultramarathon skiing quietly until the
conversation changes to a different
topic right and that's fine it's fine to
not have anything to contribute there
isn't some rule of conversation that
says every person needs to talk for
equal amounts of time sometimes you just
listen and and and maybe people won't
get to know you as much as you would
like but you know it's it's
part of its part of life and sometimes
sometimes you don't know about a thing
that other people are talking about and
I am still made uncomfortable by that
situation and I just try my best to be
like okay I'm going to listen to how
these people talk about this topic and
that's going to be interesting to me I
agree I like it when you agree with me
John no I was just trying to be in that
situation where I don't have anything to
add oh it was funny I was being I was
not get any I apologize hey John this
question is from Aoife who asks dear
Hank and John what would it mean for the
planet if the north and south pole
suddenly reversed in physics class we
were learning of that this is a
possibility but what would happen
compasses would be reversed and birds
would fly the wrong way but what other
implications would it have for us and
most importantly in what way will it
make John think about death what are you
kidding I think we'd all die if there
was a sudden reversing of polar if the
North Pole in this like if the earth
like spun upside down I think that would
be very bad for humanity it would cause
widespread death it you know it could be
very bad for Humanity actually it
probably would be moderately bad though
first I'll say that birds probably won't
fly the wrong direction birds use a
number of different inputs
in their decisions to migrate and they
may end up in the wrong spot or they may
get a little bit lost or or they might
they might die but they won't just get
up and go the wrong way they know they
know landmarks as well as as being able
to sense magnetic fields which is really
cool and burns are really sparked and
they would relearn how to migrate fairly
quickly and we've seen that when these
magnetic pole reversals happen they are
not accompanied by by the increases in
the the normal rate of extinction as far
as we can tell our graphic data what
geologic data whoa whoa whoa when when
they happen this has happened before
yeah it happen yeah it happens regularly
it happens like once every two weeks
like so like the North Pole and the
South Pole just suddenly reverse and the
entire planet Earth flips upside down
well the planet Earth stays where it is
but the the polarity of of the magnetic
field reverses and oh it's just
something that happens like deep inside
the earth with magnetic fields yes it is
if it is the effect of something that
happens deep inside the earth the the
problem is that it doesn't happen
suddenly it happens over a fairly long
period of time and during that period of
time the magnetic field is weaker and
and that's the real problem so you have
more cosmic radiation hitting the
surface of the earth we're still
predicted by the atmosphere so that's
cool but we don't have that extra layer
of the magnetic field protecting us and
that can create kind of weird-ass
atmospheric effects and you get like
localized ozone holes that might then
increase local cancer rates or you would
have to have health advisories for
people to put on more sunscreen that
kind of thing and you could also end up
with solar storms doing more damage than
they otherwise would to our electricity
infrastructure which is the thing that
we talked about previously on dear Hank
and John yeah yeah I remember I remember
how we don't have electricity for like
three three years or something yeah so
uh so yeah it could cause some some
problems it would mostly be a human
problem it would not be as much an
ecological problem animals are pretty
good at dealing with these things
turns out we think you know that problem
from our data but I don't like human
though yeah obviously human problems are
the ones that I worry about the most
because I Hank
where should I rank the polarization of
the earth switching on my list of
apocalyptic concerns very low it is a
thing that happens over a long period of
time if it were going to happen this
year we would have seen lots of effects
already though we have noticed that the
the very very slightly the magnetic
field of the earth has decreased in
power since we started measuring it so
we are probably on the way to one of
these events but it is probably hundreds
of years away okay so you would not tell
me if you would or would not change my
top three apocalyptic concerns which are
one human extinction via or dramatic
reduction in the human population via
a global nuclear conflict okay yeah I
like I like that one too
my personal death okay this would not be
apocalyptic for it would be very bad for
you but it would be it would arguably be
the worst possible outcome three the the
band the mountain goats breaking up okay
and then for some kind of plague that
dramatically reduces the human
population in quick very very quickly
like like an exceptionally virulent bird
flu or some such yep yeah I mean I do I
have it right no I would put bird flu
first I would put it I would put a
massive solar storm second and Irene I
would put global nuclear war third well
I would put in output your death first
of all of these things the most likely
of them to happen is that you will die
which doesn't actually doesn't it
doesn't make me feel better at all I
mean first off I guess that's true just
by basic laws of probability since all
of those things would involve me dying
well no no that's you'd probably survive
a number of those things you you will
being a very think I'd survive a plague
because based on everything I know about
my physical Constitution you have the
advantage of being a privileged person
and oftentimes privileged people are
more likely to survive these things and
just by virtue of being in America with
if we're talking about a significant
decrease in global population a lot of
times that has that that would not come
along with a significant decrease in
population in America where we have
resources to help us with those sorts of
things all right so just to organize my
apocalyptic concerns one solar flare
that which wasn't even on the list until
dear Hank and John to might put plague
first okay okay apocalyptic plague solar
flare nuclear mass nuclear war
is that the top-three yeah yeah alright
well I mean at least I know where I
stand and I don't like it we have a
question from David I'm god I'm glad
that you've got things to be worried
about I am also glad that I think Steve
what what would I do with my thoughts
otherwise this question is from David
who asks dear John and Hank I'm a vicar
in the Church of England and probably
too old to be a real nerdfighter I'm 33
there are lots of really old
nerdfighters who were twice as old as
you are or more - don't don't worry
about that but I love your videos your
podcast we are both older than your
older nerdfighters I love your videos
your podcast and your determination to
understand the world complexly thank you
that's very kind David what can we do to
make the conversation better when it
comes to religion in a world where
religious fundamentalism is becoming
more and more of an issue how can we
learn to discuss and understand each
other better I don't know what David's
talking about I think that we have a
really high quality of discourse on the
internet when it comes to religion I
feel like people are respectful they're
thoughtful and they never create ad
hominem attacks yeah I mean my number
one answer to this is that the only
thing that we can really do is try to
model better behavior ourselves and
there's so much at least in myself like
there's so many shortcomings in the way
that I act online and the way that I
conduct myself in public discourse that
like I can I can be busy working on that
and trying to be a better model for the
rest of my life but I think the other
thing is that we need to find we we all
need to find communities that promote
better kinds of conversation and we need
to use platforms that promote better
kinds of conversation and that's I think
what initially attracted Hank and me to
online video was watching Zafer ink and
thinking well this is a place where
people are having really interesting
intelligent discussions and that's why
we wanted to be part of it and I mean I
hope that we're still looking for those
places and I know that lots of other
people are always looking for those
places so I think we need to find those
places
encourage them build them when we can
and that's basically the Pope that I
have I'm it is very frustrating I watch
it all the time we have made it a number
of different videos about how this this
attack culture has evolved and how we
feel like you know like it has gotten
worse and then in the comments we'll
have people like saying like yes you are
right
those people totally do that and I'm
like now doing the thing that you're
saying they are doing and it right and
it's difficult to identify in yourself
but once you do it and and like and it
and like you know and continue to sort
of monitor because I still catch myself
believing these crazy things about other
people because I only get I only get the
side of the angry people you know I only
the side of the angry opposition I never
hear from actual humans who believe in
things that I disagree with and you know
it's it's a constant battle but
eventually it starts to just make me ill
to watch people I agree with make these
ludicrous and and sort of like you know
deeply flawed attacks on people that
they are are willfully being ignorant of
and and and in intentionally
misunderstanding and and doing that I
guess to mobilize the base to make
political games or whatever but I just
find it I just have started to find it
disgusting and I think that that's I
think that that that that like making
that something that is part of me I feel
like is a good thing and then like
really get being more disgusted by the
tactics than anything else yeah exactly
I mean for me it's about how we like the
way that you would talk to a relative at
the Thanksgiving dinner table with whom
you have profound political
disagreements or in
neighbor is very different from the way
we talk we're talking right now online
about all kinds of issues and it becomes
very it becomes deeply dehumanizing so
much that I think we've become
suspicious of other people's motives you
know I think the further someone is from
us or the further we feel that they are
from us the more likely we are to think
that there there's something
fundamentally different about them or
something fundamentally less about them
and the best of the internet decreases
the space between people but the worst
of the internet increases it and makes
makes it easier to see other people as
not human and that's the part of it that
just absolutely yeah I mean it's just
heartbreaking for me to see on all sides
I mean I don't think that it's I I think
that it's almost a universal way of
being on the internet right now and it's
just super depressing cats think about
there's there's cute cats in the world
think about them for a second speaking
of super depressing yeah Hank I want you
to close your eyes okay and I want you
to just whisper slowly and confidently
to yourself I am gonna charizard this
boffo I've got a Charizard this Malvo we
have a great question it's a great last
question for today because we have we
have to get to the news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon it's a question from Ben
who writes Dear John and Hank it's been
a very chaotic spring here in Sydney
Australia this year we've had 40 degrees
Celsius days
I think that's warm followed by cold and
damaging hail storms it also seems that
this summer already will be one of
extreme brushfire danger and Taylor
Swift performed in Sydney last night Oh
God to say that I am concerned after the
clear meteorological causation which
John observed in Indiana would be an
understatement are we in for a horribly
hot summer here in Sydney thanks to
Taylor Swift yes I I think that the way
that I understand climate science anyway
yeah absolutely I believe that is
correct
now you can't predict the weather
weather is different from climate Ben
that's
important but Taylor Swift does affect
the climate
I thought she effected the weather oh my
god I can't I could never remember one
it's okay Hank help me remember this
it's either Taylor Swift or global
carbon emissions that affects climate
and then the other effects like what the
weather is like on a day-to-day basis
yeah yeah Taylor Swift affects weather
global carbon emissions affect climate
though the climate does in the end also
affect weather just not not on the
day-to-day basis that we tend to think
about it
and I would say that the calm combined
effects of global warming and Taylor
Swift can only mean bad things for
Australia I do not know why you allowed
her to enter the country I think that
the larger concern is why Australia is
not doing a better job at leading the
charge against climate change but well
there's one one thing that is just much
easier to control and that is that is
the travel habits of a 22 year old woman
knowing that she brings warmth and light
wherever she goes why would you allow
her to come to an already warm and
bright country I apologize Taylor Swift
is 25 years old obviously because she
was born in obviously 1989 I didn't want
to say anything but that was
embarrassing Hank you're better than
that well I had to do real fast math Jo
guess how old adele is I think she's
also 25 so it's great that that
musicians are doing this now it's so
that we don't have to remember their
ages they just they just either title
their albums after their birth year or
after how old they are
adele is in fact 27 years old what I'm
just telling you a fact she was born on
May 5th 1988 she is 8 years to the day
older than my brother Hank
yeah younger though oh yeah right sorry
dammit I was so pleased with my joke too
bad I'm not 19 that'll be amazing Hank
what is the news from Mars
no John we
we have a couple of steps before that oh
sorry we have to tell everybody that the
podcast is brought to you by people who
recently got into competitive pokemon
people who recently got into competitive
pokemon really arousing john green's
interest i am so into Kaitlyn's
competitive pokemon tournaments I want
to you know that from now on we're gonna
get a ton of questions that are like I
recently got into competitive pokemon
and my mom is well I she's she's hiding
my money from me Hank and it's like
that's not no no no how they don't do
and everybody's gonna start the question
that way Hank if we can begin getting
actual questions from the competitive
pokemon community for more members of
that community I welcome them if it's
people who are just lying about being in
the competitive Pokemon community well
that's terrible
why would you do such a thing um today's
podcast is also brought to you by the
apocalypse the apocalypse coming soon
and we don't know how dang it you stole
mine
oh I'm sorry of course that's the one
you're thinking about today's today's
podcast is brought to you by cooperative
Internet discourse cooperative internet
discourse it's out there I guess and of
course today's podcast is also brought
to you by cows cows mostly staying where
they are today's podcast has also
brought to you by our patreon patrons
you can go to patreon
website patreon.com
where you can support dear Hank and John
directly since we don't have any ads
actual ads and you can choose whether
you want to be an AFC Wimbledon patreon
patreon supporter or a Mars patreon
supporter Hank in terribly alarming news
right now there are 3 Mars supporters
for everyone
AFC Wimbledon supporter I just don't
understand it it's a cold dead rock in
the lifeless vacuum of space well John I
do have to say however that there's a
third category
which is neither if I'm being honest
which is beating both you Mars and AFC
Wimbledon however if you combine both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon those people
outweigh thank goodness the neither if
I'm being honest people so that's that's
just fantastic news that that there
aren't more neither if I'm being honest
then people who are interested in any of
what we talked about for the last
quarter of the podcast but I understand
their perspective well the news from AFC
Wimbledon this week is that tonight Hank
tonight the Merton town council or
whatever the city counted area council
that the elected representatives of
Merton will vote on whether AFC
Wimbledon will receive permission to
begin building their new stadium in the
historic home of Wimbledon before all of
this happened before their team was
taken away and stolen away to Milton
Keynes before they restarted the club on
a public park in Wimbledon in 2001
before all of that happened their home
was plough Lane and tonight is the night
they find out from the government if
they are going to receive permission to
build the new plough Lane Stadium it
would be an incredible moment in
Wimbledon's history it would be the
fulfillment of of all of the dreams that
brought the club together in 2001 it is
a huge moment so by the time this
podcast is made and and out there will
know but for right now I am nervous and
excited and hopeful that the the town
will see fit to allow them to build a
stadium John let me know when the news
is is out so that I can put it in the
podcast description when I upload this
episode so that people will know the
news from AFC Wimbledon and not just
that there will be news from AFC
Wimbledon we promise and what is the
news from Mars there is a company in the
desert of California up while operating
a robot in the desert of California
honeybee robotics
testing a drill that could drill miles
below the surface of Mars in the search
for geological data for information on
where all of Mars is water went and the
potential of finding life on Mars it's
in that a 16-foot tall drill and they
think that they might be able to pack it
onto a spacecraft that they will send to
Mars and get send it send a robot there
to drill deep into the surface of Mars
to see what's down there because of
course most of what we know about Mars
is is pictures of the surface
secondarily we have like very shallow
scrapings and drillings from our Rovers
but really we have not gotten down below
a couple of inches below the surface and
and that would be obviously there's a
lot going on down below the surface of
Mars potentially more going on below the
surface of Mars than there is on the
surface because of this intense solar
radiation that Mars receives because it
doesn't have a magnetic field which it
once had and then it turned off
hopefully that's not what's happening
here on earth if if indeed Hanson is not
flipping but is turning off and then
that would be a truly apocalyptic
scenario however it is not happening so
that's good news okay absolutely
panicked for a second but because but
because of this bombardment that the
surface of Mars receives there's very
little going on on the surface aside
from a little bit of climatological
stuff some winds and and some great
geology but down below the surface we
have already seen that there is indeed
flowing water so that could be something
else well I'll tell you this sank when
they build the new plow Lane Stadium
there will also be drills involved but
probably the matter is just try driving
them to South London yeah you could go
to South London and look at drills or
anywhere you could go to my basement and
look at some drills but apparently the
fact that we're gonna build one that can
go to Mars is a big deal I'm just
kidding that is a big deal I'm very
excited for you I can't wait to find out
what's happening sixteen feet under Mars
miles miles sixty miles under that's
even more
that's much deeper than we're gonna have
to dig to build the foundation for the
new plow Lane Stadium so so that yeah
that's cool I don't know maybe we will
it be cool to building just a really
deep foundations if nobody could ever
move it again batter too many bad things
happen to the club we're just gonna
build a 16 mile deep foundation to
ensure that really no anyone can ever
move this come on edit of the Apes it'll
be the Statue of Liberty and this
football that's right that's right after
our magnetic field turns off and all
humans are irradiated there it will
still be the new plow lane in South
London
okay Hank well what did we learn today
we've learned that saying bless you when
someone costs is a completely acceptable
and normal thing to say and should
become more acceptable along with
gesundheit and if you want to say excuse
me when you cough or sneeze that's up to
you we also learned that there are feral
cows just not for very long we learned
that John Green has a top three
potential global apocalypse list which I
did I didn't know that was the thing
about you and now I'm worried that in
the coming weeks it's going to expand to
become a top ten list and we're gonna
have to keep track of it and make sure
everybody knows what's on top I mean I
didn't know that there was an
opportunity to share all of my top ten I
didn't know that we had time believe me
I have a top ten and of course we also
learned that soon enough we won't just
be on Mars will be sixteen miles
underneath it I don't I never said
sixteen miles I don't know where you got
that from but we will not just be on
Mars we will be in it well I'm really
bad at math so there you go not really
math when you're just making up numbers
it is it is math it is math when you're
making up numbers trust me Henry does it
every day all right well thank you all
for listening you can submit your
questions to Hank and John at gmail.com
or on twitter by using the hashtag dear
Hank and John whose podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins the theme music is from
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown
don't forget to be awesome
[Music]